INVESTIGATION, SAVE THEY FIND NO
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OR THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
AND RUSSIA.
JONAH GOLDBERG IS THE SENIOR
EDITOR AT THE NATIONAL REVIEW.
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
HOW IMPORTANT DO YOU THINK THIS
IS?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT
IMPORTANT.
I THINK WE KIND OF KNEW IF THERE
WAS REAL EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
WE WOULD HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT BY
NOW.
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH
JOURNALISTIC EXPLORATION, SO
MANY COMMITTEES, SOMETHING WOULD
HAVE LEAKED.
I THINK IN MANY WAYS THAT THIS
IS JUST SIMPLY GOING TO BE
FACTORED INTO THE NOISE ON BOTH
SIDES AS DEMOCRATS ARE ALREADY
COMING OUT SAYING IT WAS CALLED
OFF EARLY.
I AM SURE DONALD TRUMP IS GOING
TO SAY THIS IS PROOF THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION.
>> John: I AM SURPRISED IT HAS
TAKEN THIS LONG.
>> I THINK THERE ARE REAL, THE
WHOLE BALL GAME DEPENDS ON WHAT
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION FINDS.
I WILL BE SURPRISED IF THEY FIND
COLLUSION.
>> John: I ASKED IS THERE ANY
REASON TO EXPECT MUELLER COULD
FIND SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
>> HE MIGHT.
I THINK ARE IMPORTANT THINGS IN
HERE.
THINGS BOTH PARTIES COULD LOG.
THERE WAS INTERFERENCE, NUMBER
TWO, WE ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH TO
PROTECT OURSELVES FROM THE NEXT
ROUND OF IT AND ELECTION SYSTEMS
SHOULD BE HARDENED AGAINST IT.
THIS IS A PATTERN OF RUSSIAN
ATTACKS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS WIDELY
HELD AND IT'S A GOOD PLACE TO
START.
COLLUSION ASIDE.
SICK OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
RUSSIA LONGER THAN MOST PEOPLE.
THEY WERE WORRIED ABOUT IT LONG
BEFORE IT WAS IN THE HEADLINES.
WHEN THIS COMMITTEE COMES OUT
WITH SOMETHING ON RUSSIA, HE
SHOULD TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
INTERESTING THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT RECOMMENDATIONS FOR FUTURE
ELECTIONS.
PEOPLE NEED GUIDANCE ON HOW TO
MAKE SURE THEIR ELECTION SYSTEMS
ARE TAKING CARE OF.
TAKING A STEP BACK AND THINKING
ABOUT THE LARGER NARRATIVE.
WE HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO OVER A
YEAR OF A RUSSIA COLLUSION
THEORY THAT TRUMP WAS A TRADER
WHO WAS COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND THEY HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT IT QUITE A LOT.
WE ALSO HAVE THIS ISSUE OF THE
CRIMINAL LEAKS WE HAVE SEEN FROM
ALL OBAMA OFFICIALS AND OTHER
HIGHLY PLACED INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS.
THEY GIVE SOME INDICATION WE
WILL GET A LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION.
THEY ARE NOT IN THE BEST
POSITION TO PROSECUTE THE
CRIMINAL LEAKS THAT WE KNOW
EXIST.
IT'S GOING TO NEED TO CONTINUE
TO TAKE PLACE.
>> John: NO TWEET FROM
DONALD TRUMP ON THIS.
THE PRESIDENT HASN'T YET WEIGHED
IN.
THERE WERE OBVIOUSLY COMPLAINTS
FROM DEMOCRATS THAT THIS GOT
WRAPPED UP TOO QUICKLY.
YOU WILL REMEMBER A LITTLE LESS
THAN A YEAR AGO THERE WAS
CONTROVERSY OVER DEVIN NUNES, HE
HAD AN ETHICS COMPLAINT FILED
AGAINST HIM.
HE STEPPED ASIDE TO LET CONAWAY
TAKE OVER AND HE WAS CLEARED ON
THE ETHICS INVESTIGATION.
THE WAY THAT CONAWAY HAS
COMPORTED HIMSELF, DOESN'T LEAVE
HIM LAST OPENED A CRITICISM THAT
HE POSSIBLY MIGHT'VE BEEN?
>> IT MIGHT.
WE ARE IN SUCH A HYPERPARTISAN
MOMENTUM GOING TO BE CRITICISM
AND NO MATTER.
I AGREE WITH MOLLIE THAT IT
SHOULD BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
TO SAY THEY BROKE WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY'S
ASSESSMENT --
>> John: THEY WERE TRYING TO
SOW CHAOS.
>> THEY WERE UNTIL TRUMP
ACTUALLY WON.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE TWEETS AND
THE SOCIAL MEDIA.
ALMOST ALL OF THIS IS THE
GENERAL WASHINGTON CONSENSUS AT
THIS POINT.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WE ARE STILL IN THE MIDST OF
THIS COMPLETE RUSSIA HYSTERIA.
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" IS MAKING
FUN OF THE IDEA BUT WE STILL
HAVE A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
>> HOW IS ANY OF THAT NOT TRUE
ABOUT THIS?
>> WHAT'S BEING SAID IS THAT
TRUMP IS A TRADER.
>> THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
CONSENSUS.
THAT'S NOT REMOTELY PART OF --
>> I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD BE ON
RECORD, IF THEY DON'T THINK IT'S
TRUE THEY SHOULD SAY IT'S NOT
TRUE.
>> THAT'S FINE BUT THAT'S NO
BOTTLE OF ANYTHING I SAID.
>> THERE IS A BIGGER NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT,
IT'S NOT IMPORTANT AND IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
THIS IS RUSSIA INTERVENED, THEY
TRIED TO SOW DISCORD, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE ADDED AGAIN.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
PERIOD >> PEOPLE HAVE USED THIS
STORY FOR PARTISAN POLITICAL
ENDS.
WHAT MOST PEOPLE SEE WHEN THEY
SEE THE MEDIA COVERAGE OF THIS
IS THAT PEOPLE TRY TO USE THIS
TO DELEGITIMIZE THE PRESIDENT.
THIS HAS BEEN PART OF A PATTERN
OF BEHAVIOR.
BY INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS AND
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA TO CREATE
AND A LOT OF ANGST OVER THE
STORY PRECISELY TO DELEGITIMIZE
IT.
>> THE ENTIRE CABINET OF THE
ENTIRE NATIONAL SECURITY GROUP.
>> John: WE WANT TO GET ON TO
THE SCHOOL VIOLENCE POLICY, THE
SCHOOL SAFETY POLICY THE
WHITE HOUSE CAME OUT WITH
YESTERDAY.
EVERYTHING HE'S BEEN TALKING
ABOUT EXCEPT RAISING THE AGE FOR
BUYING A LONG GONE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING:
"18 TO 21 AGE LIMITS, WATCHING
COURT CASES AND RULINGS BEFORE
ACTING.
STATES ARE MAKING THIS DECISION.
THINGS ARE MOVING RAPIDLY ON
THIS, BUT NOT MUCH POLITICAL
SUPPORT, TO PUT IT MILDLY."
MOLLIE, IS HE BACKING DOWN?
>> WHEN HE WAS SPEAKING LAST
WEEK, HE WAS SAYING DUE PROCESS
DIDN'T MATTER.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT AGE LIMITS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE FOR BUYING
RIFLES.
THOSE ARE NOT POPULAR IDEAS.
THOSE ARE THINGS HE WOULD GET A
LOT OF PUSHBACK ON.
>> THE STATE OF FLORIDA, A
PRETTY PRO-GUN STATE.
IF YOU LOOK AT POLLS ABOUT THE
AGE LIMIT, 87%, 72%.
RASMUSSEN WAS THE LOWEST POLL,
THEY HAD 67% SUPPORTING RAISING
THE AGE LIMIT.
THE SAME AGE LIMIT FOR HANDGUNS.
THERE'S LOTS OF PUBLIC SUPPORT.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
THERE IS NOT A LOT OF POLITICAL
SUPPORT AMONG REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS.
>> John: THE NRA CAME OUT AND
LOUDLY WAS AGAINST IT.
>> DEPENDS ON YOUR LEVEL OF
HOSTILITY.
I DON'T THINK HE CAVED BECAUSE
HE SAYS THINGS IN THESE MEETINGS
THAT HE WALKS BACK ALL THE TIME.
THE ACTUAL THING THEY ARE
PROPOSING, THEY MAKE SENSE, THEY
ARE GOOD.
I THINK THEY ARE BASICALLY
SAYING NOW WE REALLY MEAN IT
THAT GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE
SUPPOSED TO UPHOLD THE LAW.
>> INCENTIVES TO FOLLOW THE LAW.